Jarius writing was not your career would
you still write and what would you write
that's an interesting question
no people let people often say like
people always asked if you weren't an
actor what would you do if you weren't a
set foot would you do it's hard to say
because I always was always a writer as
I always loved words my mother was
somebody who was like very word oriented
and if you use a word wrong she correct
you and she was a good crossword puzzle
person and Scrabble and she and I also
learned a lot of my love of words from
her my grandfather in an era where where
men didn't necessarily take a great
interest in you know all things
intellectual he was a he was a crossword
puzzle fanatic and he actually created
his own crossword puzzle in Cyclopes
like dictionaries basically that he hand
rode in the most beautiful handwriting
and still happened to this day and he he
was I was really young when he when he
was alive but but he really taught me a
lot about words and I learned a lot
about words from from his love of words
so that was something that came to me
from it from an early age when I was in
high school I was a film reviewer for
the high school paper I wrote different
articles the high school paper I wrote
for the literary magazine I was a staff
writer on the my college paper I was
always working I worked a lot in the
journalism world which I still do and I
so I've always loved that kind of
writing so I guess I was kind of where
it was meant to be I had a first career
out of college as a publicist movie
publicist and I did that for a while and
I enjoyed it and it actually it actually
was interestingly and actually combined
my love of movies and writing but
because because I was promoting movies
and I you know the word was so important
in terms of getting things out to people
whether it was a pitch whether was
conversation whether it's a press
release whatever but at some point I
realized I I had to I had to get back to
my first love which was writing and so I
left that world and I started writing TV
scripts and started getting work in
television and episodic television which
then sort of moved me into movies and
then stage plays and then TV movies and
all of that so it's kind of its evolved
a lot of time
you